hey this is pressure Locker this clock
displays time accurately like any other
12-hour clock but this clock has no
numbers and the clock has been rotated
out of position based on the position of
the hour and minute hands what time is
it this problem appeared as a primary
school math question in China students
were given the multiple choice options
that the time is between 3 & 4 6 & 7 8 &
9 or 10 and 11 can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution the entire difficulty in this
problem is that the clock is out of
position so we need to orient the clock
how can we do that let's zoom in on the
hour and the minute hands look at the
position of the hour hand it is
four-fifths of the way between one hour
marking and the next hour marking what
does that mean for the minute hand well
the position of the hour hand is
dependent on the position of the minute
hand if the hour hand is four-fifths of
the way to the next hour marking that
means the minute hand is four-fifths of
the way around the clock so the minute
hand is 4/5 times 60 which equals 48
minutes past the hour
therefore the minute hand is between the
hour markings of 9 and 10 and we can
continue numbering clockwise so we can
see the hour hand is past 10 so the hour
will be 10 and we know that the minute
hand is at 48 so we can deduce the time
is 1048 but just for fun let me orient
the clock in the correct position
we can put the 12 at the top and
continue numbering clockwise and we can
see the time is 1048 and that would mean
the correct answer is d the time is
between 10 and 11
did you figure out this problem thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions that you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker and if you like this video please
check on my books there are links in the
video description